では、Qiskitとは何でしょうか？
Qiskitは、オープンソースのソフトウェア開発キットです。
量子コンピューターを使って作業するための
circuit のレベルで、
アルゴリズムやアプリケーションモジュールも扱えます。このSDKは
誰でも自分のノートパソコンから実際の量子コンピューターにアクセスして
プログラムできます。わずか2行のコードで
超伝導から
トラップイオン qubit まで、複数の量子システムにアクセスできます。量子コンピューターの
動作をエミュレートしたい場合は、1行変えるだけで
高性能な quantum circuit のシミュレーションも可能です。
Qiskitは世界中の何万人もの人々に使われているツールで、
皆さんが未来を作ろうと取り組んでいます。
研究者でも、開発者でも、
これから始めたい方でも、
Qiskitにはさまざまな
ニーズに応える機能が用意されています。
誰でも、たとえば
初めての quantum circuit を作ったり、
分野を超えた量子アルゴリズムを実行したり、
量子現象の基礎を学んだりすることができます。
今こそ、あなた自身が関わるのに最適な時期かもしれません。
必要なツールがすべて揃っています。
実際の量子コンピューターも含めて、
Qiskitを通じてSDKにアクセスできます。
そして、あなたを温かく迎え、
道中のどんな質問にも答えてくれるコミュニティがあります。
今日からでも始められます。
Qiskitで。